[Music]
Kristof can I borrow your wagon and Sven
I'm not very comfortable with the idea
of that you are not going alone oh no no
I have my powers to protect me
you don't excuse me I climbed to the
North Mountain survived a frozen heart
and saved you from my ex-boyfriend and I
did it all without powers
so you know I'm coming me too I'll Drive
oh I will look after your people please
make sure they stay out of the kingdom
until we return of course let's let them
know honour
I'm worried father we have always feared
Elsa's powers were too much for this
world
now we must pray they are enough I won't
let anything happen to her this is it
everyone ready the past is not what it
seems
you must go north find the truth I'm
going with Tiana now excuse me I climb
to the North Mountain survived a frozen
heart and saved you from my ex-boyfriend
so promise me we do this together okay I
promise
need to find the answers about the past
I believe us more than anyone or
anything
frozen - it's a hole putting us in
mortal danger gonna be a regular thing
pretty peachy tickets available now
[Music]